I love all garden kind of not really but
people laugh when I say Olive Garden
like really you go to off garden yes I
do everyone I'm Charles Melton and I'm
going undercover on the Internet
it's actually me Twitter KJ appala and
Charles Milton's and real-life bromance
is really gonna change how I view Archie
and rages relationship one river down
with isn't it yeah as little bromance
outside of filming and it's funny
because like I was like you're my best
friend I was like three weeks in I just
met you dude we need to slow down you
can't be my best friend after three
weeks
moving on bubby why have I never seen
this picture of Harry and Charles Milton
maybe because you're not active on your
myspace account
oh there's zero friendship Durr it was
just a photo sorry Harry you're dope
great music my sister loves you but uh
no friendship there unless you want to
be friends
good girl on MySpace toppy posted Sophie
Frawley Vanessa Hudgens and Charles
Milton and bad boys 3 drool face I love
it
it was a great time filming with Vanessa
I'm bad boys 3 she's amazing we have not
spoken once while filming during filming
outside of filming we're not friends
that's a joke Thank You Sophie Alex
Restrepo just watch the Sun is also a
star on my flight to Arizona and all I
gotta say is what does it girl gotta do
to get a date with Charles Milton
because holy [ __ ] is he mother freaking
goddamn beautiful and charming as hell
hashtag serious I love you though
hashtag what a fox hashtag date I like
if you take me to all of garden my heart
is yours submit LP is it acceptable to
catch feelings when your celebrity crush
becomes a viral heartthrob
overnight hashtag Charles Melton when
did I become a heartthrob sure why not
yeah it's okay nobody's judging you I'm
not judging you thank you
your tweet had one link Charles Milton
how do you like your eggs cooked in the
morning sorry I was just thinking about
something very funny is a very bad joke
very perverted how do you like your eggs
in the morning I'm not gonna say I'm not
gonna finish it I don't know if you guys
are familiar with this stroke but it's
pretty funny
I love Eggs Benedict I loved eggs
benedict so post what a perfect eggs
benedict submit at some times Nike how
does Charles Melton space even exist ask
my mom and dad well first comes
intercourse I'll just stuff there that
new Charles Melton and Yara Shahidi
movie is a scam who wouldn't fall in
love with Charles Milton's John one day
can you please send me messages like
this every day to boost my morale
confidence it's very sweet but I'm more
Jat than just a jaw I'm more than my
deep set eyes I am more than my Beyonce
s clips I am more than my small ears I
am more than my crooked nose yeah I know
I have a good nose I don't need anybody
to call me out on that
yeah I'm just more than everything you
see I think can we talk about how
Charles Melton met NCT 127 yesterday and
today he met BTS that man is living my
dream life I swear to God by the way
grandchild I'm not trying to call you
out you didn't say I swear to God you
said is T G come on 40 what that means
well I'm a huge fan and I'm cream as
well so NCT 127 was on James Corden
during that appearance that I had pretty
great pretty cool and then I met BTS at
Good Morning America my sister was there
my sister loves BTS I only became a fan
of BTS because my sister she was losing
it
but you can never tell like she plays
this so cool like I could tell she was
losing him because how many times she
pulled out her phone that was her
expression I'm like oh my god you know
she's like really chill but I was pretty
cool she was so excited
Wikipedia he studied at Kansas State
University where he played on the
football team yeah I played full by
Kansas State University
I played safety and Kansas State
University for Bill Snyder and if you
don't know who Bill Snyder is then you
don't know college football boom he also
previously worked as a dog walker on the
app Mike I did work as a dog walker on
whack I walked over 300 dogs in two
months
I still get notifications on my phone
for people requesting me to walk their
dogs it boosts my morale sometimes you
know in lonely days I'll have like five
notifications on my phone all from my
dog requests that's it not my mom
nothing just dog requests next his first
acting roles included guest spots on
Glee and I'm wearing in horror story yes
Glee season 5 episode 5 for 3 minutes in
don't take a bathroom break you'll see
me for about 43 seconds I don't know I
don't know that Instagram hello what
hair product do you use how's this golf
I use it every day I'm very passionate
about houses scoff its it means a lot to
me I just mix it up I really don't do
anything yeah I just keep it messy and
greasy don't wash it juju derps
hey Dad I was wondering if I can go out
with some friends tonight someone's
photo I'm holding a newspaper I guess I
look like a dad maybe in some weird way
yes you may
you don't my 10:00 p.m. don't go past
second base it's cool though she said
hey dad instead of hey daddy
which is completely
Kika Zoid have you ever gotten stuck on
a photo shoot I feel like if I tried to
lay on a two-seater I'm 6 feet tall I'd
get stuck
I've been on some weird photo shoots
Kiku's word I've never been stuck in a
chair but I've been on some weird photo
shoots that I left I show up to this
photo shoot and the Wardrobe was a
fishnet pearl necklaces and a yellow
plastic hat in speedos as it
I was not stuck I left I stood to what I
believe that which is no fishnet no
yellow hat no pearls most beautiful
blast that Roger how do I get Charles
Melton haircut I thought I had bad
grammar but Roger you and thank you it's
not just me
see when I both learn this together how
do I get Charles Milton haircut call
Mara she does my hair makeup gives me a
haircut all the time she gave me a
haircut yesterday she's great if you
want my Instagram you could find her
he's got cool tattoos a little bird
hands why not
she's Asian reminds me my mom but like
yeah okay cool
YouTube Jordan page hmm I don't want
remember this episode of Riverdale
neither do I but I understand why you
may think it's Riverdale because of the
lighting and it's very cinematic and you
see my face
and you see my face in Riverdale so I
get it it was never on Redang it's a
music video
Aaron st. Joshua anyone know where I can
find a shirt like Charles unless you're
gonna pull my skin and wear me no I do
not know where you can find there stir
it like Charles but I know you're saying
we're the same we have a terrible
grammar anyone know where I can find a
shirt like the one Charles is wearing
just call my stylist Petra Cora
who is Charles Milton Charles Milton is
figuring it out submit I discovered a
lot today thank you for tuning in
watching GQ peace
[Music]